immer ein spannendes Thema die
Religionen und darüber zu diskutieren
aber Herr dohrendorf hat heute auch ein
spannendes Thema mitgebracht was sie im
Moment sehr beschäftigen das ist nicht
Frau Roth und nicht die Religion nein
das ist halt die Verteidigung
die sollte das andere sein die für mich
als verbotspartei einfach sieht also am
liebsten möchten Sie dass wir kein Auto
mehr fahren das kann man hier in der
Stadt gerne wollen das kann man auch
machen ich komme aus der Fläche aus dem
schönen Landkreis Lüge dann weg und
Lüneburg da geht es eben nicht der
zweite Punkt ist ich soll kein Fleisch
mehr essen das ist ja so immer am besten
ähm und am besten auch die Jagd sollte
man eigentlich verbieten bzw die Waffen
dann auch Zentrallagern und das sind
alles so Punkte das finde ich halt
einfach schade und da ziehe ich
natürlich nicht mit ich sage diesen
Veggie day den wir ja mal hatten jeder
Politiker der also in Vegi der fordert
für den da freue ich mich auf ein
schönes Stück Fleisch dass ich auf den
Grill lege
provozierend mal gesagt und ich finde
einfach es geht einfach Arbeit auch bei
der Jagd wir haben 44 Rudel in in
Niedersachsen und fünf einzelne Wölfe
was die anrichten aber die Grüne sind
nicht bereit dort in dem Bereich
wirklich sich ein bisschen zu öffnen und
wenn man sieht was das für die Fläche
heißt in der Stadt ist es alles
wunderbar aber wenn Sie mit dem Hund in
der Fläche spazieren gehen und Sie
wissen nicht kommen jetzt ein Rudel
entgegen was passiert jetzt eigentlich
oder wenn sie sehen wir haben sehr viele
Reiterhöfe die dann nach ihrem springen
und nach Frisuren einfach im Wald
ausreiten wenn die den Wolf mitbekommen
die Pferde dann gehen die einfach durch
ist und einfach überall wieder gefahren
und wir müssen einfach in dem Bereich
offener sein und das ist bei den Grünen
nicht so der Fall kann sich heute auch
extra jagdlich angezogen und mein
Statement zu setzen nein nicht unbedingt
ich trage sowieso ja jagdliche Kleidung
auch als jagdpolitischer Sprecher der
CDU und in der CDU-Fraktion in
Niedersachsen aber ich fühle mich auch
in dieser Kleidung wohl und nach außen
zeige ich das natürlich auch weil man
natürlich auch mal gerne Gegner
miteinander wir wollen ja reden wir man
kann ja nur Menschen überzeugen indem
man halt und für mich ist das Bio also
das Wildfleisch für mich das beste Bio
Fleisch was es gibt insofern bin ich
auch Verfechter und nicht nur Fleisch
ist sondern auch von diesem köstlichen
Fleisch und insofern großartiges Rehwild
ja
noch haben wir es noch haben wir es äh
der Wolf hat bei uns völlig die das
Muffelwild schon dezimiert das gibt's
nicht mehr jetzt geht es gerade ans
Damwild und wenn das nicht reicht weil
das sind so Fluchttiere die nicht ganz
so schnell sind dann geht's an die
Schafe an die von uns an die Rinde
wir wollen ja nicht ausrotten und wir
haben 44 Rudel das ist nur für
Niedersachsen dann kommen Brandenburg
Sachsen-Anhalt noch dazu nein ich möchte
den regulieren dass wir eine Untergrenze
wie in Frankreich haben und alles was da
drüber ist ob das nun 80 oder 100 Würfe
sind die müssen dann geschossen werden
so einfach ist das wie bei jedem anderen
Wildau
neben der Jagd kommen wir zum
eigentlichen Thema der verbotspartei die
Grünen würden sie das unterschreiben
kann man das so sagen dass die Grünen zu
viel verbieten wollen zu viel regulieren
wollen wie Herr Dorndorf ist
angesprochen hat also ich würde es ein
bisschen weiter ziehen tatsächlich also
ich glaube die Grünen sind so eine Art
Avantgarde eines bestimmten Zeitgeistes
und der ist in der Tat also etwas
paternalistisch und ja auf eine
eigenartige Weise obrigkeitsstaatlich
also ich finde die Ansprache der Bürger
hat sich sehr geändert ich beobachte das
besonders stark seit Corona es hat aber
möglicherweise auch schon vorher
angefangen aber also insofern es war
nicht allein ein Problem der Grünen
sondern es fing eigentlich in der
Regierungszeit von Frau Merkel an zum
Beispiel wenn ich erinnern darf also an
ein relativ unterirdische Werbekampagnen
wie meine
Disziplin ist unsere beste Medizin also
das hat eine Bundesregierung plakatiert
das tut keine Bundesregierung die also
sozusagen in in ihren Staatsbürgern
Erwachsene mündige Menschen sieht
sondern das ist im Grunde genauso ein
Schritt in diese Richtung also
Infantilisierung des Bürgers und ein
sehr herablassendes paternalistisches
Verhältnis das setzt sich jetzt fort
also mit großen Kampagnen ja auch aus
dem aus dem Hause Habeck zum
Energiesparen und aus dem Hause
Lauterbach mal wieder zum Impfen und
jeweils eigentlich also natürlich gibt
es da dann irgendwo noch Fakten Blöcke
in den Begleitmaterialien und so weiter
aber die Kampagnen sind eigentlich rein
werblich und rein moralisch und das ist
glaube ich der Zeitgeist den die Grünen
besser als alle anderen verkörpern das
moralisieren von Diskussionen also nicht
zu sagen ich finde dein Argument falsch
und zwar aus folgenden Gründen und kann
dir vielleicht die Zahlen nennen und
überdenkt das doch noch mal sondern du
bist ein böser Mensch wenn du diese
Meinung vertrittst und das hat sich
leider sehr ausgebreitet und ich glaube
das macht unseren politischen Diskurs
ziemlich kaputt
sind ihn bei ihren Recherchen der glaube
ich sehr sehr oft begegnet
vor allem während ihrer corona-recherche
natürlich also wenn wir über die Grünen
sprechen dann hat der Dorendorf ja eben
deutlich gesagt dass die Grünen das
Fleisch essen und so weiter verbieten
und ich habe so ein bisschen immer den
Eindruck dass man den Grünen irgendwie
nachsagt so die ganzen Dinge die jetzt
vielleicht mal angegangen werden müssen
dass die das kreiert haben und da kann
ich nur sagen ich habe das vorhin gehört
mittlerweile Fridays for future
demonstriert ja sogar gegen die Grünen
also man darf jetzt nicht sagen nur weil
da eine grüne Farbe ist dass die immer
alles irgendwie in diese Richtung Natur
nachhaltig und sonst muss man ganz im
Gegenteil es gibt ganz viele
Fleischesser bei den Grünen es gibt ja
auch Fleisch die im Supermarkt also
jetzt nicht so als wäre fleischverbot in
unserem Land ja genau also aber es gibt
einfach sehr viele Fleischesser bei den
Grünen also da ist das gar kein
richtiges Argument zu sagen die Grünen
würden dass die machen das gar nicht
also die verbieten vielleicht Fleisch
aber eher aus monetären Gründen oder
weil ihnen die Welt sich so gut gefällt
da habe ich ja eben schon von mit
angefangen aber ich habe ein bisschen
Expertise ich habe in den 90er Jahren
das ist ja schon für viele junge Leute
ganz weit weg habe ich mich für die
Rechte der Tier eingesetzt und habe da
also gesehen dass das ganz interessant
ist ich war so ein Legebatterien ich
habe in massentierhaltungsbetrieben habe
ich mich umgeschaut dürfen und können
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen die
corona-zeit hat mich sehr daran erinnert
dass wir das eigentlich schon haben und
dass wir im Grunde genommen in der
corona-zeit mit Lockdown mit Masken und
so weiter mit Impfungen
ja das ist aber so also weil
letztendlich müssen sie ja nur nach
China gucken da sehen sie es noch mal
ganz extrem da werden ja ganze Städte
abgeschlossen wegen der corona-maßnahmen
und da werden da wird ja umgegangen wie
mit ich sag das jetzt mal mit Phi und
die werden komplett in rechnet und damit
kann man ja sehen dass auch das Vieh
also die Tiere die eine Seele haben und
ein Geist haben die werden auch komplett
entrichtet und niemand spricht darüber
und ganz ehrlich ich war in den 90ern 95
war ich aktiv und was haben wir heute
2022 das sind jetzt 27 Jahre
ganz ehrlich das ist eine Katastrophe
dass das nicht weiter gekommen ist okay
es empfehle Ihnen viele Leute jetzt
vegan und vegetarisch und so weiter ich
finde das gut ich esse überhaupt gar
kein Fleisch ich es einfach die Angst
der Tiere nicht damit denn die haben
Angst und dann muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen das sind aber nicht die Grünen die
das nach vorne treiben damit man denkt
man moralische Aussage weil wenn sie
sagen sie essen kein Fleisch sie essen
die Angst der Tiere nicht dann fragen
Sie im Umkehrschluss
ich esse gerne Fleisch sehr gerne ich
esse auch Rehwild ich finde auch die
Jagd gut das heißt sie sagen mir jetzt
eigentlich im Umkehrschluss ich esse die
Angst der Tiere das ist ja was
moralisierendes was eigentlich auch nee
weil das sind ja für physikalische
Vorgänge wenn also ein Tier zur
Schlachtung geführt wird müssen Sie
immer damit rechnen dass dieses Tier das
merkt das gleich was schlimmes passiert
und das werden sie auch merken wenn sie
vor irgendwas Angst haben mir passiert
in ihren Zellen auch irgendwas und da
brauche ich gar keinen Mediziner oder
Biologe zu sein da weiß ich dass das mit
Sicherheit sich nicht gut auswirkt da
werden Sachen ausgeschüttet im Körper
die sie damit Essen und das ist ja nicht
moralisierend wir fragen die doch einmal
Herr Doro die These mitgebracht hat und
hier auch der jagdexperte ist kann ich
denn noch weiter mein Rehwild essen oder
esse ich die Angst des Tieres mit und
werde daran
wir trainieren ja das ist einfach so
üben und wir schießen so dass also
wirklich auch das Stück im Schussfeld
das heißt das ist ja auch wir auch in
südamberg haben wir ja sehr viele
Muttertiere das heißt also ich meine von
von den Rindern her das heißt die die
Leben auf der Wiese und die sind nachher
so wild dass man sie nicht mehr zum
Schlachter ziehen kann sondern dann
werden sie auch geschossen und das geht
ganz sanft muss ich ganz ehrlich
aufhören dass sich komisch anhört aber
das was sie sagen
wirklich so und das was sie sagen haben
sie haben vollkommen recht darum bei den
Schlachthöfen und so weiter wird das ja
eigentlich auch schon so gemacht dass
man versucht die Schweine und die Rinder
so zu transportieren und in die Räume zu
führen dass in dieser adrenalin-ausstoß
weil das kann man nicht tatsächlich
Corona sah das ja genauso aus bei der
Qualität vom Impfzentrum Schlange stehen
das Säge das gleiche genau also auf
jeden Fall
nicht relativ einfach und da ist es halt
einfach optisch dass man dass man da
halt natürlich die Möglichkeit hat dass
das Stück nichts merkt aber es geht ja
auch um Preise und ich finde bei der
fleischdebatte wird auch oft vergessen
wenn man jetzt sagt Massentierhaltung
nein das ist natürlich moralisch richtig
aber irgendwann sagt man ja dann auch
dass vielleicht Geringverdiener kein
Fleisch mehr essen können weil sie sich
nicht leisten können wäre das denn
richtig nein das ist natürlich nicht
richtig und was heißt Massentierhaltung
also ich kenne auch viele Biobetriebe
wenn sie mal sehen wie viel tausend
Schweine die haben natürlich haben die
eine andere Fläche weil
Massentierhaltung
machen viele an der Anzahl der der
Stücke fest das ist eben falsch sondern
es kommt natürlich auf die Fläche an und
wir müssen natürlich auch produzieren
diese produzieren nicht nur für
Deutschland sondern auch für andere
Länder und da haben wir auch einen
entsprechenden auftragen wir haben ja
eigentlich die schärfsten Kontrollen
überhaupt in Europa das ist ja auch das
große Problem dass unsere Landwirte
haben das in anderen Ländern wie Polen
da wird das erst zehn Jahre später
umgesetzt bei uns wird es meistens immer
sofort umgesetzt und das eine großes
großes Problem und darum brauchen wir ja
natürlich auch den die konventionelle
Landwirtschaft damit wir auch die die
Leute die nicht so viel Geld haben auch
natürlich versorgen können aber es hat
sich ja unheimlich viel schon getan also
es ist ich finde es ist immer die Frage
wie erreicht man denn eine
gesellschaftliche Verbesserung also ich
glaube wir können uns wahrscheinlich
darauf einigen dass es bestimmte Arten
von Massentierhaltung gibt die wirklich
Tierquälerei sind und das möchte man
nicht unterstützen indem man das kauft
und gleichzeitig wenn man sehr wenig
Geld hatten möchte man vielleicht
trotzdem auch mal irgendwann vor 27
Jahren oder oder vielleicht essen aber
es hat sich tatsächlich ja aber das
Bewusstsein hat sich es gibt natürlich
viel mehr biologische Landwirtschaft
jetzt ökologische Landwirtschaft und ist
die Menschen versuchen ja gute Produkte
zu kaufen wir haben eine Kennzeichnung
jetzt also aus welcher Art von Haltung
kommt das ich finde man kann auch
darüber diskutieren dass man sagt möchte
ich lieber einmal Rückgang des
Fleischkonsum genau es gibt auch leckere
Sachen jetzt also die ersatz-burger
schmecken auch viel besser jetzt aus zu
erbsenproteinen oder so als vor 20
Jahren insofern das ist doch eine eine
schöne evolutionäre also eine
vernünftige Entwicklung zum besseren
aber das kann man doch mit Argumenten
tun und Diskussionen und eben nicht mit
der mit der Vorschrift also ich möchte
eigentlich lieber dass Menschen in einer
Demokratie sich frei entscheiden können
zu solchen Dingen und nicht darüber kann
man hart streiten aber man muss also
nicht den Veggie verordnen
nein und es hat ihnen sehr geschadet
übrigens also sozusagen dafür haben sie
aber der Wahl dann direkt die Quittung
gekriegt bei der damaligen hier wird
geschmunzelt links sehe ich ja ich bin
weder Politiker noch mache ich mir da
bisher in großparteiprogramm
irgendwelche Gedanken zu aber ich habe
es anders mitbekommen und es ging es ums
Massentierhaltung und vernünftige
Herstellung von Nahrungsmitteln da war
nicht nur Fleisch mit gemeint ja das
heißt wir haben eigentlich ein Problem
wie wir unsere Nahrungsmittel
produzieren vor allen Dingen wie viel
wir davon wegwerfen oder nicht als zum
Essen gebrauchen ja da müssen wir uns
umstellen und ich hatte es auch von den
Grünen nicht anders wahrgenommen dass es
da ein Punkt ist dass es zugespitzt wird
dass mir kein Fleisch mehr essen sollen
finde ich dann übertrieben ich esse auch
gerne Fleisch ich esse aber vor allen
Dingen gerne lecker ich esse eben auch
neu entdeckte Magic Gerichte wenn sie
gut schmecken ja und vor allen Dingen
wenig Chemie in beinhalten sondern eben
Nahrungsmittel die man auch zum Essen
gemacht hat und nicht irgendwelche
künstlicher Form irgendwas nachbaut also
ich bin auf dem Bergmannstraße
gewesen da hat man versucht die
Currywurst Veggie nachzubauen ja das war
eine chemiewurst ja die mag so ähnlich
geschmeckt haben aber ich würde sie
allein deswegen nicht kaufen weil
daneben an die normale wusste gibt warum
soll ich dann die Kunst Wurst essen und
ich glaube nicht dass das unser
politischer Weg ist zu sagen der
verbieten irgendwas oder wir teurer dann
irgendwas sondern ja sondern wir müssen
einfach neu nachdenken wir hatten auch
noch kein Corona und wir hatten auch
noch keinen Ukraine gekrieg als wir die
Diskussionen vorgeführt haben deswegen
müssen uns glaube ich an unseren in
unseren Leben an das Anpassen was wir
gerade geboten bekommen und dass wir
Energie anders brauchen können als sie
wegzuwerfen das ist auf jeden Fall
richtig